une colonne noire impressionnante
visible à des kilomètres aux alentours
d'auxerre il est un peu plus de 17
heures et le feu se propage à une
vitesse incroyable dans cette casse auto
500 voitures vont partir en fumée en
quelques minutes
heureusement aucun salarié aucun client
ne sont blessés je suis un peu retourné
on va dire c'est quelque chose qu'on
n'imagine pas arrivé
grosse partie de notre exploitation qui
part qui part en fumée
des pompiers près d'une centaine au
total viennent en renfort de tout le
département
car la crainte est que le feu ne
s'étende aux mille autres véhicules
également stockés sur ce site dont la
majorité n'a pas encore été dépollués
les services de secours savent qu'il
faut aller très vite
il met moins de deux heures pour stopper
un incendie ce qui concerne la pollution
sur plan atmosphérique
elle est négligeable les fumées se sont
dispersés très rapidement et donc on a
une problématique qu'on surveille de
près qui est l'écoulement des eaux
d'extinction
puisque la rivière l'yonne est à côté
une enquête a été ouverte pour
déterminer les causes de cet incendie
dont on ne connaît pas encore toutes les
conséquences environnementales des
analyses seront menées par la direction
régionale de l'environnement et l'
agence régionale de santé